[Music]
this saturday marks 20 years since the
september 11th terrorist attacks 10
years ago a book was published featuring
the letters that family members wrote to
loved ones who were lost on that
terrible terrible day it is called the
legacy letters we met up with three
young people whose letters to their
fathers were included in that book and
they reflected on the past 20 years and
shared their stories of resilience
olivia you were ten
on you were four lauren you were eight
um on 9 11.
i just want you each briefly to tell us
what you remember about that day and the
days following olivia you start please
um i can walk you step by step through
the 11th
it was one of the first few days in
middle school for me olivia perez's
father anthony perez was working as a
technical specialist on the 103rd floor
of the north tower on september 11th
kids were being pulled left and right to
go home early it's fifth period and i'm
in orchestra
and um
they wound up pulling a kid and come on
miss tell us please tell us and just i
don't know i'm not supposed to but okay
you know the world trade center had been
attacked and it was just an instinctual
i mean the sinking feeling in my stomach
you knew your dad was there yeah and i
knew he was no longer here lauren what
do you remember
i have almost the opposite experience if
she can walk you step through step
through her day i've got
five minutes
lauren charette's father mark charrette
usually worked in his office in new
jersey but on september 11th he was
holding an annual planning meeting on
the 100th floor of the north tower
my mother knew he got into the city that
day she sat me and my the older of my
two brothers down and told us that the
towers have been hit
i know i asked her something i couldn't
tell you what it was
[Music]
and then i know several days later and
this conversation i don't really
remember very well that she must have
sat us down a couple days later it was
definitely the weekend and told us he
was dead the only memory i have in
between about it is somewhat recess when
we still weren't sure because i know
somebody was saying something and i know
i got super upset
on you were four
yeah so my account of the at that very
day and the days that follow is
it could be even more vague and hazy
um but i do recall that my father tried
to wave at me yelling my name telling me
to wave through the window of the school
bus
which was something that he never would
never really recall he did otherwise ann
newen's father ken nguyen who lived
through the vietnam war worked in the
navy command center at the pentagon
i noticed that my father didn't come
home i honestly thought that he would
come back at some point and it was a
couple weeks later when the funeral came
when i saw my father's casket was pushed
into the cremation chamber that's when i
knew that
he's not going to come back
it took
even a couple more years after that even
to thoroughly understand
that he's not going to come back and try
to live my life
and develop my identity
without
my father
on lauren and olivia mark the 10th
anniversary of 9 11 by writing legacy
letters to their fathers
dear dad you're the greatest man i could
ever know i'm sure any girl who loves
her father as much as i do would say the
same
but from the short time i got to spend
with you
i know you were the greatest person
alive
now that another 10 years have passed
they look back at those letters
reflected on what they mean to them
today
and what did you want to say
in that letter
you know i don't even
it was cathartic i want him to be proud
i want him
to know that
though his life was cut short that he is
leaving a lasting impact
on the planet
he was
my everything you know
my favorite photo of us
is the one taken on my third birthday
you let me sit
on your shoulders
and we laughed and looked so happy
i am saddened
and sometimes angry
that i was forced to grow up
without
a father
i had learned about terrorism
and the war on terror
a lot of people will not understand what
the word terrorism
means until
you're
directly impacted by that
lauren um what struck me about your
letter it was a series of questions
and i loved your questions because it
was something that we could all relate
to i'm graduating in june will you clap
for me do you think i've made good
friends
i stopped going to church doesn't matter
when you get this will you write back
do you miss me as much as i miss you
will you be at my wedding
do you think i'm picking the right
career
do you still love me
most of all i wanted to ask am i still
your little girl
still your little girl
that question really got to me because i
think every daughter at some point asked
that question of her father it was a
haunting question to me because you
can't get the answers to any of the
questions but they're all questions that
we want to know the answers to
so i shuffled it i think a couple times
but that one was always last it was
always last that was the place to end it
that was the one i wanted the answer to
the most
on you said you promised in your letter
to your dad
that you would make him proud when you
became a man do you think you've done
that yeah ten years later
now i'm about to turn 24.
i feel like i did
grad school is about to be done about to
be finishing up in december
and
that degree was an honor from my father
because he didn't get the chance to
complete his
you all talked really about making your
dads proud
olivia i honor my father every day by
doing something stupid to make someone
smile
and that was anthony perez in a nutshell
i go into work every day with that
because at the end of the day my father
went to work
and he never left i'm still questioning
it i still don't have the answer um if
you've made your dad proud you don't
have the answer yeah no
why not lauren
i don't know every time i ask it of
myself i'm like well what am i doing
with my life now it's like
i like your answer i think i definitely
make like people's lives better so i'd
like to think he'd be proud of that but
i don't have the answer lauren the fact
that you're still here and you're
carrying on your dad's legacy
is really more than enough sitting here
and listening to these these two
beautiful stories i mean my heart is
just breaking yeah and i just want to
give them the biggest hugs right now so
i definitely find a lot of comfort
um being with them
i love talking to them it was comforting
to me to talk to them as well you know
they said the hardest thing about
september 11th is august the month of
august because they know it's coming the
run up to august the interviews from the
media start coming in people start
saying how are you how are you doing and
sometimes they said we want to
acknowledge it other times we don't want
to do anything neither lauren or olivia
have ever seen any footage of 9 11.
they've never looked at it gail it's so
powerful i i have no words no i don't
know well done